hello again this is the newshour from al
jazeera adrian finnegan here in doha
there's been a large explosion in
lebanon's
capital beirut within the last hour
let's show you some latest pictures
uh it's clear that uh there was a
massive explosion
as you can see we're not quite sure yet
as to what
has caused this explosion but
if you can see the pictures of the
neighborhood now in which this
explosion happened you can see that it's
caused
widespread damage we have no information
yet as to uh
how many casualties uh there might have
been
uh it's clear though that uh that
something has caused
a very large explosion in lebanon's
capital within the last hour al
jazeera's zayna hodder
is in beirut and is on the line for us
now
zaina uh you must have heard this
explosion
not only heard it adrian felt it it
shook
the lebanese capital i have reported
from this city
for years but never felt such a massive
explosion first there was a thud and
then a gust of winds
glass everywhere destroyed i am seeing
ambulances
uh carrying wounded rushing to the
hospital
there's chaos in the streets it's still
not clear the cause of this explosion
some reports are suggesting that it
happened
at beirut port it is still not clear
like i told you but i was kilometers
away
the glass broke everywhere around
me and as you can imagine this is a city
which is used to explosions
assassinations but it has been a while
uh since the last
well it's too early to say bombing
because some reports
are suggesting that there was a a decal
that exploded at baby sports like i
mentioned
it's still not clear what exactly shook
the lebanese capital but as you can
imagine people are worried phone lines
are jammed
people are trying to reach their
relatives calling family members to make
sure that they're okay
so this is all i can tell you at this
moment
a massive explosion you you obviously
aren't able to see the pictures we're
showing right now but we have
uh pictures taken from uh the water
near to the port area and and it's clear
that there is
a very large explosion right on the
coast there
where in the city zaina are you right
now
not very far from the port adrian at
this point in time
some roads are blocked so it's very very
difficult to move around
the security forces are directing
traffic towards
one area um as you can imagine there's a
lot of chaos
i saw the puma spoke massive uh
like i mentioned a massive explosion
we're still trying to confirm exactly
what happened at the beginning
just a few minutes after the explosion
as you can imagine
there were reports saying that it was
close to the house of the former prime
minister zad al-qaeda
and then reports emerged that no that is
not true i'm in fact standing outside
his residence
and nothing happened here so it is still
too early for us
to confirm uh but this is really
a country that that is drowning
an economic crisis a political crisis a
currency crisis so people are already
on the edge and that is why many are
just
concerned what exactly happened like you
mentioned it's close to the sea
it's close to beirut port we are still
trying to confirm
exactly what happened and what caused
this massive explosion
the the pictures that we're showing show
a thick plume of
black smoke rising over the port and
then what appears to be
a blast wave so maybe there was a fire
first
before the explosion tell us something
zaina of the port itself
yes adrian sorry i didn't hear i didn't
hear you very well
the cars are honking like i told you
there's panic industries everybody's
trying to get home
glass everywhere so i could imagine the
injuries just
as a result of a broken glass
i was close to the american university
hospital that's in the heart of beirut
and glass was falling from the seventh
floor from the sixth floor people
were trying to uh to to find cover
so there is still chaos people are
trying to get to their homes
it was the first day after a five-day
lockdown was listed as
the authorities had the imposed five-day
lockdown to try to curb the
the increase in the number of
coronavirus cases so this country is
really tackling
with many many crises a health crisis
a currency crisis an economic crisis a
financial crisis
and now with this bombing you can
imagine how concerned people are
but again we don't want to jump into
conclusions i do not want to call this
an attack i do not want to call this a
an assassination attempt right now all
we know
a massive explosion took the heart of
the lebanese capital
just a few minutes ago everyone tried to
retold
everyone concerned that this could be
if indeed it was an attack and i repeat
we still have no confirmation if
this was an attack uh it could be the
start of
even more instabilities for a country
really that hasn't
seen stability for decades this uh this
explosion
was clearly big enough to cause a blast
wave
uh which has from the pictures we're
seeing here uh caused
significant damage several kilometers
away there are cars that have been blown
upside down or what they appear to have
have been hit uh by something which has
which has thrown them into the air
buildings damaged several kilometers
away in the city itself
uh it looks as though this explosion as
you say was at the port zainab i don't
know whether you can hear me but
i just wanted you to tell me a little
about the port
itself in beirut
yes adrian the force of the explosion
was felt across the city
their initial reports are suggesting
that explosion
was in the port and i can tell you we're
just we are approximately five six
kilometers
away from the port and the whole
building our whole office
uh uh the building the building where
our office is located
the glasses is in the streets so it is
still
not clear what exactly happened we are
trying to make calls
to figure out what exactly uh
happened but the damage the damage
kilometers and kilometers away and it
was the force the force of the explosion
i was i was walking in the street and i
was thrown to the ground and
i'm telling you i'm not close to the
pool i wasn't close to the port
so adrian until we get more confirmation
i cannot say whether or not this has
been an attack
or whether it was some sort of accident
yeah
it it i mean it appears from from
from looking at this the fact that that
it happened at the port
uh that this may have been uh an
industrial accident something that has
gone terribly terribly wrong
at the port itself that has caused this
this clearly massive explosion and you
said you felt this blast wave which
which appears from the pictures we're
seeing here zaina to have caused
so much damage right throughout the city
you felt it yourself
yes i did i did adrian massive massive
explosion the force of the explosion you
mentioned an industrial accident we
cannot rule that out
uh we have to stress this time and time
again we cannot pull that
out for the time being until we confirm
exactly
what happened until we manage to reach
the site of this explosion
but if you tell any lebanese now that
this was an accident
it will not calm their nerves because
the lebanese people have been on
edge for some time now i talked about an
economic crisis
a state close to bankruptcy a currency
that has devalued
more than 80 percent in the past few
months inflation
storing food prices a surge in corona
virus cases
the health care system close to collapse
so
people are dealing with all these
problems and then
they feel an explosion that blocks their
capital
and this is a country that has seen
massive explosions
i'm not linking this explosion to
anything
but just let me tell you in two days
time by the end of this week
lebanon was expected to hear uh from the
international tribunal
which has been investigating uh the case
of the assassination of the former prime
minister rafiqul hariri
that was back in 2005 and that explosion
was just as massive as this
one and that explosion was a political
earthquake
the whole not just the capital the whole
country shook
following his killing three days from
today
the verdict is going to be issued this
will be the first time in
history that an assassination or a
political killing
is investigated and murders murderers
are uncovered
and uh and at least attempt to to bring
them to justice
so you already have all these
this this political atmosphere in the
country
then you hear this massive explosion so
could you imagine what is going through
the mind of every lebanese now as they
try to confirm exactly what happened
so we cannot we cannot say whether or
not
this is an explosion whether it's an
attack or whether it is an industrial
accident
we're seeing pictures which uh
show clearly signs of of
absolute devastation at the port area
these pictures appear to be
the site of the uh the explosion itself
there you see that massive
blast wave uh heading out across
uh the capital beirut uh
firefighters can we go back to those
pictures at the uh at the scene of the
uh
the the the explosion we don't know
uh uh there it is again firefighters
tackling
uh what has remained that what it
remains of the the fire there after the
explosion
uh mangled buildings in the port area
cranes
uh still standing despite that blast but
that roadside
uh close to the port area where we saw
cars that have been overturned
people lying injured and bloodied on the
side of the road
people standing around as you can see
they're stunned
after after what has happened there at
the port in beirut and al jazeera zaina
hoda is making her way
to this this site right now and she's on
foot uh
listening to us uh on for where where
are you now uh
zaina how far away uh from the port area
are you
senator i don't know if you can hear me
uh how
close now are you to the port area
no we've appeared the line has dropped
uh for the moment
i will come back to worsener uh as soon
as we can
so what do we know um within the last 30
40 minutes or so reports began to come
in
of um a huge explosion
in beirut the lebanese capital
uh when the first pictures started to
come in
i mean they're they're unbelievable what
you're seeing right now
mangled buildings cars uh it appears
that this
explosion happened in the port area in
beirut we have no idea yet
as to what caused this as xenohoda was
saying to us earlier this is a city
that's
used to explosions
and attacks but this was on a scale
rarely seen in that city a massive
explosion there and we we simply don't
know the cause of it yet we don't know
yet
uh either how many people uh were caught
up in this explosion whether there have
been deaths there have certainly been
injuries
as they were saying that massive blast
wave that we saw
uh from those initial pictures showered
the city
in shards of glass and damaged buildings
it almost looks as though there's been
an earthquake
in in some parts of the city itself
further away
from the blast we're seeing
pictures of injured people lying on the
road
near the road pictures of upturned cars
there
on that road passing the port there
where cars have clearly
either been involved in in traffic
accidents as drivers were distracted by
the blast or have been blown over by
that massive blast wave
that we saw on the pictures
we're trying to re-establish contact
with uh with zaina hoda
and we're trying to talk to other people
trying to get hold of other people
in the city who can give us
there excuse me their experiences
of what happened in the last hour in
beirut
so if you've just joined us this
is excuse me i'm just going to clear my
throat
this is al jazeera live pictures from
lebanon's capital beirut where within
the last hour
there has been quite clearly a massive
explosion
the site of the explosion reported to be
well
you can see it from the screen the port
area in the city
a massive blast wave has damaged
buildings mangled buildings a fire
is still raging firefighters
tackling that that blaze that blast wave
has damaged
buildings kilometers away in the city
itself has showered
the city with uh with shards of glass
blown out windows
uh for kilometers around uh
and as yet we have no indication as to
the number of deaths or injuries but
it's clear
that after something like that on that
scale
that there will be casualties the
emergency service is trying to deal
with um clearly a massive
explosion like that are going to be
overwhelmed as
our correspondent was telling us that
even though
beirut is um almost
used to explosions over the years rarely
has it seen anything
on this scale so this appears to be the
seat
of the explosion which happened
uh within the last hour our
correspondent zaina hodder is is making
her way
to uh the the sight of that uh explosion
and we'll
as soon as we've reestablished contact
with her we'll um
we'll talk to her some more about her
experiences
um those pictures we were showing you a
few moments ago of of the fire
um the seat of the fire the seat of the
explosion apparently there are people
trapped
under that rubble which is what the
emergency services are um
uh are are doing they're trying to work
uh
trying to get those people uh free uh
zaina's back on the line
uh zaina where where are you now yes
lions are apache as you can imagine
adrian everyone is using their phones
the
network is jammed everyone concerned
about their loved ones trying to find
exactly what happened uh what shook the
lebanese capital just under an hour ago
we are still trying to get confirmation
what we understand for the time being
some sort of an explosion at beijing's
court
beirut force is located really in in the
heart
of of the lebanese capital we still do
not have
uh confirmation on casualties and
injuries as you can imagine
uh there's chaos it's very difficult to
move uh some roads are blocked and then
there's traffic congestion in some areas
there's panic in the streets glass
everywhere uh the force of the impact
the impact the force of the explosion
was
massive um the the wind
people people initially everyone
what what came to their minds is that
this is another assassination
lebanon for for many years was rocked
by a series of a string of
assassinations
uh political killings but it has been a
while it has been
uh quiet for some time now but again
there's no confirmation some reports are
suggesting that this is some sort of an
accident
at uh beijing's force maybe a fuel depot
some reports also suggesting fireworks
nothing that we can confirm at the time
being
all i can explain all i can tell you is
what is going on in the street
and all i can say is chaos fear uh
nobody knows what happens damage
uh kilometers and kilometers away i
could imagine how many people
were sitting in their homes when when
the blast shook their apartment and
glass the
glass broke everywhere so there is
there is concern but there's still no
confirmation
adrian on what caused this
explosion it's clear that there will be
uh multiple injuries after something
like this
zaina uh the city's emergency services
working
uh tirelessly as we speak yeah
given this is happening in the middle of
a pandemic will will
the the hospitals in the city be able to
cope
this is a very good question because the
health care
system is already collapsing
this is a country the
in deep economic crisis financial crisis
a currency crisis private hospitals are
owed
billions of dollars by the lebanese
government
a government that is cash trapped and
bankrupt
so private hospitals have begun to turn
away patients
for some time now and
public hospitals are underfunded and
they have been raising the alarm that
they could no longer cope with the
rise in coronavirus cases so
there are many many crises
in lebanon at this point in time
a bombing a political assassination will
definitely not bode well for the
disability but
as we have to stress time and time again
we still do not know
the cause of this massive blast we are
still trying to confirm
and trying to reach the fight of the
explosion this is
um we're finding difficulties reaching
some roads have been blocked and as you
can
imagine a traffic congestion just to be
able to move from one area
uh to another uh we were looking at
pictures
we're still on uh the pictures are
coming from the road which runs adjacent
to the port there in beirut
scenes of of complete chaos
mangled it looks like warehouse
buildings at the port there
cranes blown askance
many people standing on the roadside
there
um completely bewildered they're taking
photographs of something they're on the
opposite side of the road to the
explosion
uh not sure what that is but we're also
seeing
pictures of cars that have clearly
either been involved in traffic
accidents immediately after the blast oh
it's that building there which
uh which has been completely blown out
uh as you can see
uh by the force of that blast
from the port uh which is just opposite
the cars that have been
either involved in traffic accidents but
you know as drivers were
uh distracted by the the explosion right
next to them or have been blown over by
that massive blast wave
um let's speak to reporter angel vara
who
uh is also in beirut uh your house
anshun i understand was damaged by the
blast
that's correct about half an hour 40
minutes ago we were just watching a show
on netflix taking a break from work
and i heard of a jet hovering in the sky
and because this has been happening for
some time
i opened the window glass door and
looked outside
and the entire building shook and i was
blown by it
my entire house has been formed
everything has been bombed
i'm bleeding on my neck uh i think
there's i think it's glass on my neck
and my ankle
i would say i'm seriously injured but a
lot of people around me on the street
where i live in
which is called james a christian
dominated area a lot of people are
bleeding
there's absolute chaos here people
cannot understand how to react to this
situation this country has already been
grappling with so much earlier in the
day i was filing a story on how the
price of bread has doubled
but how are these people going to deal
with the situation now my entire
neighborhood has been formed
thankfully my neighbor is okay i haven't
yet many
i haven't yet i don't know if there are
any casualties yet or not because i'm
right
under my house but my entire house was
blown apart
there's nothing that i could actually
pick up from there other than my phone
luckily i found my phone
and i found my passport is with me
we're on the street right now also on
the job trying to film trying to talk to
people and understand what's happened
other journalists now collecting at the
same spot we're outside the red cross
a lot of people trying to go in i
haven't yet managed to get to the
building
red cross i don't know whether it's been
found or not but a lot of the buildings
here have been formed just people around
me
bleeding everywhere complete chaos
i mean you know one doesn't want to sort
of talk about who's done this yet but
deaths have been hovering above
hovering above these skies over the la
for the last two months now
so complete chaos uh many were
anticipating this but it's just such a
heartbreaking moment
personally but also as somebody who
lives in lebanon for me
i can associate with the lebanese people
these people have been going through
such a hard time and now this i mean one
just you know does not have work how to
describe this
this situation that we're in and charles
it's clear that that from what you were
saying you've been injured by flying
glass there
and and and you're bleeding are you
getting are you getting treatment for
that are you able to
to get medical assistance
no no no medical assistant i i don't see
that cross i see one red cross
the uh running around uh in a parking
lot
trying to help an elderly lady
but as i said i i don't know if i can
get to the red cross building and it's
very close to my house
and because i'm limping as i said my
ankle is bleeding
i haven't managed to get there yet and
it's complete chaos because
all the cars on the streets people are
rushing to pick up the wounded
uh lots of old people i see at least
four or five now
i see two more red cross
red cross workers now some young people
trying to help
uh uh others around it's just completely
cured cars have been bombed houses have
been bombed
this is a really posh area in lebanon
you know one would think that this is
an area which would not be bombed by uh
the southern neighbors because it's
christian dominated and people here have
generally felt very safe in that regard
but this is the first one to go through
this
uh uh to go through the situation here
today and child
i don't know whether you're aware yet
obviously i think you're in a state of
shock but there's been the explosion was
at uh was at the port in
uh beirut how far away from the port is
your is your neighborhood
but we're about i think we're about uh
30 minutes away from it but the fact
that that's been bombed as well as
you're saying we did hear
uh my husband is german and he's a
journalist as well and he just got a
message from the german embassies that
that in fact has happened
and uh um uh if that's happened to then
this
makes the situation much much severe uh
i mean
this sort of you know this sort of a
sort of an event
i mean i really can't even get into the
politics of it all to be honest because
i have people bleeding in front of me
and old man
i reckon would be 60 plus is bleeding
he's lying on a stretcher now
a red cross man is a red cross worker is
dealing with him
he's trying to address to his wounds
there's another
really old lady on my right he's being
taken care of
uh uh she's been taken care of by some
people around me some young people
i mean it's just an absolutely it has an
absolute nightmare
you know we've all read about these
things happening in lebanon but that it
would actually happen
you know this is the 5 to 15 years right
after the 2006 four that this would
actually happen
no one don't believe that one thought
that somehow
some somehow peace would be maintained
somehow
lebanon is not going to go in this
direction
it was already dealing with so much but
here we are
young people have of course been hit as
well a young lady is
sitting on a on a what would have been a
window once
and this is this is the parking lot
right in front of my house
the parking lot right in front of my
house just like about 100 meters away
from red cross
a very hot area market had opened up
after lockdown was lifted
and and another nurse from red cross has
just come to this parking lot
with some bandages trying to cater to
people who've been injured
hopefully i'll get some first aid as
well
it's a really dire situation here look
we'll let you go and get get
that ankle treated that that bleeding uh
stemmed
uh look take care of yourself and um
we'll give you a few minutes to to
gather your wits again and we'll come
back to you many thanks indeed that's um
reporter angel vora there
uh who was at home watching tv when that
blast hit
uh her neighborhood uh a couple of
kilometers away
uh from the port area in
beirut when that explosion blew out all
the glass in the windows
of the homes in her neighborhood uh
anchal's
neighbors like her injured by flying
glass
she's got uh her ankle she said was was
bleeding
she's clearly i mean you can hear it in
her voice when she's talking
in a complete state of shock there so
um we'll let angel go and uh and get the
treatment she needs
she said there's a red cross uh first
aid worker there treating people in her
neighborhood